I think this I think so but I think it
goes back to how many people do like if
you think that you're I've seen people
do it ready to put the trailer up and
then they put a third person in the
description of what they do and it's and
then you see who started it and it's
done then you're looking like why were
you talking about yourself in the third
person and why is this the trailer that
you made a urine like sit and you want
thirty thousand dollars like you
wouldn't take the time to talk to me on
camera you're a filmmaker and you talk
about yourself in the third person who
the are you where's your agent give
a business rep is our appraisers rep is
what what the just say hi I'm a
human being you're a human being I'm
trying to do this were you give me my
money to do this not just Joe is a blah
bitty blah who did bloody but I don't
want a reward and here's a trailer that
has nothing to do this campaign at all
that's existed just because able to see
how good it will see how many awards won
at festivals that does not motivate
human beings but that's how we all get
sold Oscar winner Oscar nominee sure you
think at that little spike but the
people that make the most money at the
box office don't win Oscars most of the
money those made in the entertainment
industry doesn't win that's how they pay
the bills iron man
no special effects you know ten poles
that's how they think we don't leave
contempo we don't mean that spike we can
be very little band and any little
storytellers that are underground that
don't have to play that game and can
keep going and sustain ourselves because
we don't have to play that it's easy
talk to the audience that's that's why
you started with in with you started to
get higher do you want to sell stories
to an audience that's what I wanted I
mean I love getting higher I love
getting things people keep hiring me to
tell stories now's a freelancer a little
bit little bit it's great it's a blast I
have fun doing it and and the reason I
get those jobs well what did you do oh
my go here's your's vampire mom here's a
music video and then they hire me to
make their corporate you know video and
I do what I do you know and when they
say well we think a green screen about
about yeah that doesn't sound fun green
screen nah want to do this yeah that
sounds fun good good that's enough
telling stories and that's I think is
like I don't feel like I'm not a perfect
videographer I don't shoot for Miss
prism things and you know it's it's some
company wants to do something it's like
well this is who I am this is what I do
so this is what I'm going to do for you
with your story tell me what you need to
tell I'll tell you my idea we up for on
the same page then we move on then I so
I can make a little bit of a living
doing that I do other things that I'm
working on and I think that that's
sustainable to me smaller you know not
buying a house in the hills and lived in
the hills bunch of up
there takes forever to get down from the
hills you can't walk out the
door my cup coffee better get your car
so they've living in burbank like way
out Alan I know how a VC human beings
not just rich driving bomb hey
Justin Timberlake um so I don't I don't
I think there's going to be a blue
collar story Toller I think there's
gonna be working class store until I
think it's like people who work below
the line in Hollywood who nobody knows
it's gonna be like that maybe directors
and storytellers and but we're just
we're just people tell stories it's not
something big nothing special about it
nothing oh my god how do you anybody can
do yeah it's not top down I think it's
so because I've had people tweet me like
I can't believe you're talking on
twitter and I'm like why look cuz you
make that chill and a movie I'm you know
I'm raising my kids and I'm like we just
have different jobs and I'm drinking
coffee right now you're drinking coffee
right now oops to deal with I've
got some to do ur and partners
should i deal with his telling stories
and ferns should give you with his
raisin cake that particle boat key over
both humans
calm the down like there's no
there's no about web celebrity I don't
want to be ridiculous the idea what yeah
it's pretty good being famous on the
Internet you know who said me that's so
cute now's our opportunity not to be
can we all just stop being
anam an alpha
you